in this video you're going to learn how
to write quadratic equations in vertex
form by completing the square we're
going to work with two examples one
where a is equal to one and one where a
is not equal to one so let's dive in I'm
going to go through the steps you're
going to want to follow so let's dive
into this first example y = x^2 - 14x +
1 so we're trying to take it from this
standard form into this vertex form and
so the first thing you want to do is you
want to subtract the constant to the
other side of the equation basically
what you want to do is you want to get
this one kind of out of the way so I'm
going to move it to the left side here
by subtracting
one okay so now that gives us y - 1 is =
x^2 -
14x okay so now what we want to do step
number two is we want to factor out the
leading coefficient this a value here
the number that comes in front of the X
squar term so in this case you can see
that leading coefficient is just a one
so factoring out of one is really not
going to do anything in this particular
problem but in the second one we do
it'll be important now for step number
three you want to take B / two the
quantity squared and you want to add it
to both sides and I've got this note
here that you're going to want to be
careful and you'll see how that plays
out in the second example so remember
our B value is the number that comes in
front of the X so in this case that's
the -14 you might want to do this work
off to the side you take -14 / 2 that's
B / 2 the quantity squared that's -72
which is 49 and what you're going to
want to do is you're going to want to
add 49 to the right side you're going to
want to add 49 to the left side to keep
this equation balanced now we're just
going to
simplify okay so y + 48 = x^2 - 14x + 49
we want to factor the perfect square
that we created that's this guy right
here this perfect square trinomial and
when you factor it it's going to factor
into a binomial Square
it's always going to be half of this B
value so it would be x - 7 the S if this
was + 14x it would be + 7 so always half
of that b value and then for the last
step we want to get this y by itself
step number five so here we're going to
subtract the
48 to get it over here to the other side
and that's going to give us let's see Y
is
equal x - 7^ 2 - 48 now we have in the
vertex form we can see our vertex is at
pos7 -48 remember the number that's
grouped with the X has the opposite
effect the minus 7 is actually Shifting
the graph right seven if it was plus 7
it would go left seven and this K value
has the same effect it's going to go
down 48 let's take a look at another
example okay for number two now let's
take a look we've got f ofx = 5x2 - 40x
+ 7 the F ofx you can think of this as
just y okay okay just for Simplicity
sake so what we're going to do is we're
going to follow these steps we're going
to subtract the constant to the other
side now when I say subtract if it was a
negative 7even I would just add the
seven to the other side we basically
want to move the constant to the other
side just to get it out of the way so
we'll subtract seven from both sides
okay so that's going to give us y - 7 =
5x^2 - 40x okay step number two now we
want to factor out the leading
coefficient that's the a value the
number that comes in front of the X
squared term and when I say factor out
this leading coefficient this five some
students mistakenly factor out the
greatest common factor which would be 5x
we just want the a value just the five
so just be careful with that so that's
going to be x^2 minus 8x and what I like
to do also is put a little space here
because we're going to complete the
square now if you get a little bit
confused about this factoring out what
some students like to do is just put a
little fraction bar and you're dividing
by five so what I'm doing is I'm just
reducing see x^2 8X okay so now what we
want to do is we want to figure out what
B / 2 is squared so this is the
completing the square process we say
okay here's our B
value8 it's a number in front of the X
we're going to go over here to the side
B / 2 squared 8id 2 is -4 -4 2ar is 16
so I'm going to add 16 here and this is
where you want to be careful because it
looks like we're adding 16 to the right
side of the equation right but because
the 16 is in parentheses it's actually 5
* 16 which is 80 that we're adding to
the right side of the equation in effect
right so we have to add 80 to the left
to keep this equation balanced are you
with me you don't want to just add 16
and 16 you're going to get the wrong
answer it's actually five time 16 out of
thin air we're adding 80 to the right we
want to add 80 to the left step number
four we want to factor the perfect
square that we created here
and remember the little shortcut for
doing that it's always going to be half
of this B value so it's going to be x -
4 the quantity squ if this was Plus 8 x
it would be x + 4 okay so now we'll
simplify on the left side this is going
to be y +
73 okay and now the last step is just to
get y by itself by moving this constant
to the other side so I'm going to
subtract
73 from both sides of the equation keep
it balanced so we get y y =
5 * x - 4^
2 - 73 and that's in our vertex form you
can see our vertex is going to be at
pos4
-73 remember it's the opposite here the
number the group with the X it's the
opposite if this is plus4 this would be
ne4 this one's the same effect it's
going down 73 the five is our a value
that's stretching the graph by a factor
of five that's going to make it narrower
it's going to go up faster and you got
it so if you want to see more examples
you want to test yourself you want more
practice which I recommend follow me
over to that video that I did there
we'll get some more practice I'll see
you over there